one of the things that you are
ooh I think I hear you say is pay for
talent yes oftentimes people assume that
if you're involved in philanthropy
you're taking a vow of poverty right and
it's hard to attract challenge you're
trying to resolve the world's greatest
problems on the cheap right how is it
and this is what I think you also bring
to this conversation that if you want
talent you must be willing to pay for it
we do you agree with that is that part
of your philosophy yeah I i think that
there's a new paradigm that's happening
which is the potential employee is
willing to work for slightly less than
they would in a down in Wall Street per
se because they want to work for an
organization that they believe is doing
something you know that's a line with
their admission and I think
organizations realize they need to pay a
little bit more for that talent and so I
see that happening i see it whether it's
small companies or in the the large
environmental groups they're bringing
people in from people who've come up
from nonprofits but also people who have
come from the private sector because
it's a different world and this this
feeling of here's the nonprofit over
here and here's the for profit i think
people you know in our generations
anyway I want to do something I will do
something that's good and and they're
doing it people in their 50s are leaving
their first career and they're going to
that you guys get a chance to do it the
first time around